hey guys it's Monday April 25th I'm Mary
and you're watching snooze news because
it's after PAX East and there's not a
lot of news to be had and my voice is a
little sore and I'm pretty tired
we're gonna do it anyway we also got
three pretty good stories for you we got
John Romero we got Ubisoft and we have
porn for some reason video games
[Music]
first up doom co-creator John Romero has
announced a new project it's called
black room doom co-creator John Romero's
new studio night-work Games has
announced black room a new first-person
shooter that set to recapture the
gameplay in action of his previous games
like quake Romero added that his
upcoming shooter will feature a similar
gameplay to what he's done in the past
like rocket jumping strafe jumping and
circle strafing and of course shooting
but he added that black room will also
get a large focus on narrative it's
going to be that kind of classic
gameplay he said the experience that you
had there is what I want to make happen
in black room but I also want to have
that narrative that half-life 2 does so
well that's integrated into the gameplay
so he's making half quake 3 you have my
attention Romero on top of the
single-player black room will also
feature a variety of multiplayer options
like co-op 1v1 deathmatch and
free-for-all arena in six built-in
multiplayer maps game will also include
full mod support and the tools to create
community maps I already said you have
my attention Romero but you have my
attention
black room is set for release on PC &
Mac in winter 2018 currently on
Kickstarter with a funding goal of
$700,000 with rewards like a physical CD
of the new soundtrack by acclaimed metal
guitarist George Lynch getting your face
on an npc in the game and designing
weapons and monsters it's gonna be
popular there was a drama bomb going on
this year between Assassin's Creed
co-creator Patrice days delay and
Ubisoft today they call the truce
Ubisoft an assassin's creed creator
Patrice days lives settled a year's long
dispute regarding the mysterious game
1666 Amsterdam as part of the agreement
announced today in a press release from
Desilets new game studio panache digital
games the developer has regained the
rights the game from Ubisoft under the
terms of the agreement de soleil has
agreed to drop his 400k lawsuit against
Ubisoft going forward de stelae will
have all creative and business control
over the project putting aside our past
differences Petraeus and I are above all
interested in the creation of video
games and the evolution of this medium
of entertainment this agreement is good
news for everyone as everyone's always
said Patrice is a talented designer and
we wish him all the best in the
development of his future endeavors
good on you Ubisoft everybody get back
to class this fight is over
finally major pro gaming league ESL band
you porns gaming team for porn reasons
major eSports organization electronic
sports league is severing ties with
adult website you porns professional
gaming team team YP this is being done
according to a rule that blocked
sponsors who are quote widely known for
pornographic and other adult mature
themes and products and quote according
to games beat team YP tried on numerous
occasions to alter its branding and
messaging to appease ESL including
changing its logo and name to say YP
instead of youporn
additionally the organization adjusted
its SEO so that when people searched for
team YP on google they wound up at a
safe for work team YP site frustrated
gamers will have to fully type out porn
like everyone else to get their kicks
ESL stated advertising pornography is
not legal in the market that we operate
in and the vast majority of partners
were working with have strict no drugs
no alcohol no pornography no fun rules
that we've contractually taken on board
I added no fun these aren't new rules
but ones that have been in our rule
books for a long time so that's all I
have for you today but I will be back
again tomorrow and for the rest of this
week actually as Jess in the news team
take a much-needed week off so I will
see you guys again tomorrow have a good
one
[Music]